- [J.R.] Art is not supposed
to change the world.
But art can change the
way we see the world.
So now my wish is--
for you to stand up for
what you care about.
By participating in a global art project,
and together, we turn the world inside out.
(piano music)
- [Announcer] They had a big
idea to change the world.
But they couldn't do it alone.
- [Woman 1] So my wish--
- [Man 1] So my wish--
- [Man 2] I wish--
- [Man 3] So now my wish--
- [French Man] And now here's my wish--
- [J.R.] My name is JR.
I like to call myself an artist.
There's two ways of
thinking about my work.
The easy way is just I'm just papering
black and white images on walls.
But I believe my work is
about connecting people.
For me, it's the power of
bringing people together.
I went there to do art
projects with the community.
Now I realized the community
wanted to do art projects
even more than I wanted,
and start thinking, why don't I
take myself out of the
equation and let them do it.
So the wish was pretty simple.
Is you just put up a website and
you can send us your photo
for whatever you believe in
or whatever you wanna fight for.
We'll send you back your
photo in large format
wherever you are in the world.
Every day I seek roles,
living around the world.
The project went much further
than the places I've been,
and that shows the power of art.
And the photo booth
truck is the magic of it.
- [Woman 2] We're a team of four
traveling in the photo booth truck.
Josh, Basel, Jaime and I.
- [JR] We are reusing
two of these trucks
to cover 30 cities around America.
- [Woman 2] For just a
tool for people that wanna
send a positive message.
- [JR] Once the truck
is ready and running,
anyone can come, wait for the flash,
touch the screen, take your
picture, type your information.
In a matter of a minute or
so, it prints on the side
three by four feet.
No one is used to seeing
their faces so big.
The truck has this magic
about bringing photography
back to the print.
Then the posters go to the wall.
We use wallpaper glue,
put them up, and that's it.
We printed more than
300,000 faces already,
and we sent them to
more than 130 countries.
- [Luana] It's the people's art project.
We don't decide the message.
It can be political to
bring attention to issues.
- [JR] I love the idea of using
photography to promote change.
This specific project
is to raise awareness
about the Dreamers situations.
- [Karina Ruiz] Inside Out is
bringing the opportunity
for Dreamers like myself.
A person that came here at a young age
to have a better future.
To come out and give a face to the issue.
- [VIANEY PEREZ] When people drive
by and they see a lot of faces,
they're gonna get curious
and they're gonna wonder
that's the face to the issue.
To humanize it.
- [JR] You do this thing
that just pasting an image
up there might have no impact,
but it does have an impact.
You cannot know when and
how, but it's worth trying.
It all starts with believing, right?
So, if you don't believe
that you can make change,
change will never happen.
Even if it's a very small
change in one person,
that's a positive change.
This is not about JR anymore,
it's about everyone that believes
that art can change the world.
I think that definitely art can change
the perception we have about the world.
And if we start seeing
the world differently,
maybe it's a good path to
start changing the world.